well I'd like to talk a little bit about
baseball in particular I have two
numbers 714 and 715 now one reason I
think many mathematicians really love
baseball is because it's at the base of
it when you watch it on television it's
a fairly boring game
it's slow-moving and it's filled with
numbers the sports casters always talk
about batting averages they talk about
on-base percentages they talk about
records like the most homeruns someone
has ever hit in their career or in a
particular year or whatever Babe Ruth
who is one of the greatest baseball
players of all time he played for the
Boston Red Sox and then very famously or
infamously was traded to the New York
Yankees over his career he hit 714 home
runs this was a gigantic record who
towered over everybody else and was
thought that this record would never be
beat fast forward to you know later in
the 20th century 1960s and 70s and we
have Hank Aaron who played for the
Atlanta Braves who was closing in on
Babe Ruth's record it really captured
the nation's attention and in fact there
were lots of overtones involved with
this
Babe Ruth played for baseball at a time
when baseball was segregated all of the
players were white after World War 2
baseball became integrated Hank Aaron
was african-american he was met with
many racist attacks for trying to beat
the the record of of the white space
ballplayer Babe Ruth and through all of
these really ridiculous and stupid and
vicious attacks he kept his dignity and
kept his cool and he just you know kept
on doing what he does best which is play
baseball and so it transcended just the
sports moment and and in fact the number
714 and 715 carried a weight with them
did anybody in the US at that time would
know what those numbers were referring
to without even mentioning Ruth Aaron
we're baseball so I'm a mathematician
I'm watching the game 715 is hit there's
a ceremony on the fuel the game the star
for the ceremony and it's a wonderful
moment and then I'm thinking okay these
are numbers I'm a number theorist what
can I tell you about the numbers 714 and
715 so the first thing I try is I try to
factor them they're not hard to factor
714 its prime factorization is 2 times 3
times 7 times 17 7 15 that's also easy
to factor 7 15 is 5 times 11 times 13
and what do we notice but for these
Prime's that are involved they are all
of the primes up to some point so in
other words if I multiply 7 14 times 7
15 and factor that into primes I get
every single prime appearing up to 17
isn't that interesting two consecutive
numbers their product is the product of
all of the primes up to some point now
you can ask how special is this property
does it ever happen again or does it
happen for smaller numbers well you can
see that it does happen for smaller
numbers for example five and six work 14
and 15 work you start searching for
larger examples in seven 14 and 7 15
good luck you are likely not to find it
and it's not known if there are any
larger examples but we can't and we
can't prove it but we strongly think
there are no larger examples how has
that been like a search of notes or
someone put these into a computer and
let it run for a few weeks or well we
tried this at I was a professor then at
the University of Georgia and we tried
this I and a few colleagues and I don't
remember how far we got but it denote
when you take a product at consecutive
Prime's up to some level and multiply
them together these number these
products grow exponentially in fact I
believe it's a consequence of the ABC
conjecture that there should only be
finitely many examples anyway the next
day when I went into work I spoke to a
colleague and I said can you find an
interesting property of 714 and 715 and
he after a few minutes found the same
property that I did but then he went
into his class and asked us
can anybody in this class find an
interesting property of seven 14 and
seven 15 and one of the students found
another property that's also amazing
what if I change these time signs in two
plus signs so you know that's perverse
but let's do it so we add two plus three
plus seven plus seventeen that adds up
to 29 and if I do it for seven fifteen
and add them together that also adds up
to 29 and here we were able to find more
examples probably infinitely many
examples of this although although rare
we wrote an article for a non serious
mathematical journal to give you an idea
of how non serious it is the name of the
journal is the Journal of recreational
mathematics in this article we had lots
of jokes and we may you know had fun
with all of these interesting properties
of 714 and 715 we also had a conjecture
and the conjecture was that these pairs
of two consecutive numbers whose primes
add up to the same thing this is a Ruth
Erin pair and we conjectured they thin
out the technical name is have density
zero anyway
it turns out that this whole thing which
started as a joke this article was read
by Paul air dish who is one of the most
famous mathematicians from the 20th
century he wrote a letter to me saying
that he can prove that the root aaron
pairs thin out and he wanted to come to
georgia to discuss it with me this is
incredible here i am a young beginning
professor writing a joke article for The
Journal of recreational math and then
one of the greatest mathematicians of
the century should write me a letter
saying he wants to come and discuss it
so he did he came he discussed it with
me we wrote a joint paper he started
learning the tricks of his trade and he
mentored me and we ended up writing over
20 joint papers before he passed away in
it completely changed my career and the
funny finale for this for the story is
that in 1995 I believe Emory University
in Atlanta gave Paul Erdos an honorary
degree air dish invited my wife and I
for the party before the evening before
to celebrate the recipients of the
honorary degree and it turns out that
there was another person there also
getting an honorary degree at the same
time this was Hank Aaron when I got
there I just couldn't believe that Hank
Aaron who is the reason for some sense
that I met Polaris in the first place
was was there in the same room with Paul
air dish so I went up to Aaron and
introduced myself and I said that his
baseball feat completely changed my
career as a mathematician well he looked
at me in a very puzzled way like maybe
he had just met a crazy person as usual
with him he was very magnanimous and
calm and pleasant and I introduced him
to era dish and they had a nice
conversation and there's a photograph of
them sitting at a table together one of
the Emory professors who was there knew
that Aaron was coming and had brought
some baseballs for Aaron it's a sign
which is sort of a customary thing to do
to have a great star athlete sign a
baseball as a memento so he gave me one
of these baseballs and I had Aaron sign
it and then I had orders sign it and you
know people have air - number one if
they ever joint paper with air - will I
argue that Aaron should have air -
number one he doesn't have a joint paper
but he does have a joint baseball what
happened to the baseball where is it
well one of my students gave me a little
plastic box to put it in so preserve it
however not ever having had people
signed baseballs before I had they
signed it with a felt-tip pen and within
about a year or two the the signatures
had faded and now maybe if you were a
great forensic expert you could maybe
find those signatures on the baseball
but I they're essentially invisible it
just looks like a a new baseball
notice you published in this area you
like to review for us and Peck said sure
so Peck started reviewing papers and he
reviewed one appointments papers which
is a little incestuous P was again
George Purdy at Cincinnati I'm the G C
was Chung been John Kay was quite me he
was early it's good to have a vowel